scp-049 versus scp-106  will the classy intellectual plague  doctor with a deadly touch finally be  able to defeat the ruthless calculating  old man with an unstoppable fetish for  pain let's find out both have deadly  anomalous abilities concerning touch the  plague doctor stops hearts and the old  man melts flesh however it's unlikely  that either would be as effective in  combating each other as they would  against non-anomalous humans but it's in  the other anomalous effects that a clear  winner comes through while scp-049 can  create an army of zombies numbers mean  nothing in  scp-106's pocket dimension so if ever  the fight was taken there we think 106  would have a clear advantage